I have some sadly really disturbing
numbers to give you about shootings in
America recently I told you we did a
story I think it was about ten days
after the Las Vegas shooting and at that
point a couple hundred people had been
shot in the United States and of course
with much less fanfare much less media
drama than the Las Vegas shooting and I
have some even more really sort of
stunning but also depressing numbers for
you today which is that between the Las
Vegas shooting that took place October
1st and the shooting at the Texas church
that took place just a few days ago in
Sutherland Springs Texas 4319 people
have been shot in the United States and
thirteen hundred and eighty five of them
were killed okay between the two mass
shootings Las Vegas shooting October 1
Texas shooting November 4 Las Vegas 58
people shot dead Texas 26 people shot
dead 84 people total shot dead in those
two incidents tragic horrible absolutely
sickening but the degree of violence
that we're experiencing is unique to the
United States among developed nations
you really have to go to countries that
the US doesn't consider really our peers
to find rates of gun violence and gun
death this high and between the two
shootings which combined took 84 lives
1385 lives were lost in small shootings
and the victims are varied in terms of
age in terms of location in terms of
ethnicity and education income
employment 22 year old black woman from
not too far from from where we are
Pittsfield Massachusetts an 18 year old
Hispanic woman from South Carolina was
shot and killed a 54 year old white
woman in Arizona was shot dead a 37 year
old white man in New York City a 17 year
old asian kid in Georgia shot dead and
why does this matter right it matters
because talking about shootings as one
thing doesn't make any sense I've said
it before and I will say it again there
are mass shootings there
our individual shootings there are
double homicides there are suicides with
guns and we should be trying to prevent
all of them and the ways that we might
go about preventing mass shootings for
example are not the same ways we might
go about preventing individual shootings
which of course kill way more people in
total but fewer people per incident and
that gets me to one of the main sort of
fallacious ways that the pro-gun right
thinks or at least claims to think about
gun safety no matter what proposal gun
safety advocates make right no matter
how well backed by research it is no
matter how well backed by data it is you
will have people who will say hey you
know what that particular method makes
no sense because it wouldn't have
prevented this type of via of gun
violence or that particular shooting
that's not a reason not to do it that's
a reason to do it along with many other
things yes it's true there might be some
tactic or change that could be made
which would prevent or make more
difficult or less deadly mass shootings
but it's true that more than likely the
way to prevent mass shootings is not
going to prevent gun suicides that's a
reason to do different things to prevent
each and not reason to do nothing and
this is becoming more and more common
among the so called gun rights advocates
who appear in the media whatever you
proposed they'll come up with a scenario
and they say hey it wouldn't have
prevented this one if you do that you
wouldn't have actually prevented the
Aurora movie theater shooting he still
could have gotten his guns or whatever
oh here's a way you could have prevented
the Aurora movie theater shooting well
that wouldn't have prevented the Texas
mass shooting because that was a
different type of scenario that just
tells us there's not one solution that
tells us the problem is so deep and so
ingrained in our culture and our society
that there is not going to be one
solution to fix the entire problem
that's a reason to do more not less it's
sort of like when a regulation that is
in place isn't enforced the left says oh
we've got to put more resources behind
actually enforcing it and the right will
say hey see I told you regulations don't
work
cancel all of them it's fallacious
thinking it makes absolutely no sense